Thank you so much for listening to this episode and yeah, thank you so much for listening
to the Software Freedom Podcast then without you, our dear dear listener, this podcast would
not be possible.
This podcast is brought to you by the Free Software Foundation, you know, we are a charity
that empowers users to control technology.
Today I am here with my colleague Dario Presutti. Dario works on legal and policy topics.
You have a policy background, Dario. Can you give me some background how you ended up
at the FSFE and how come that you were so interested into Free Software?
First of all, hello Bonnie and hello everyone. I am really happy to be here. It's a pleasure
to be here, to be in the Software Freedom Podcast, which you all. So yeah, I have a policy
background. I also have, let's say, my Gresham Studies background, but somehow ended up
working in Free Software. And this is because during my studies, I did an internship with
the Italian Foreign Ministry at the European Parliament and I really became involved and
interested in European politics. And at the same time, at the end of my studies, while
I was finishing my studies, my brother was finishing his studies and I studied something
much more related to Free Software, which is software development. And somehow, when
we were talking about our studies and what we were doing and what was interesting for
us, I came across something called Free Software or at the time, I came across the word
open source and I became really interested in that and I started reading this, but then
I didn't really get involved until I moved to Berlin and if some of our listeners
don't know, FSFE office is in Berlin and I was looking for an internship after my studies
and that's how I found out about the FSFE and all the work that the FSFE is doing in
the realm of politics and technology. So already more than two years ago at the beginning
of the 2023, I started my internship at the FSFE and that's also how I became always
more interested and involved in Free Software and all the policy and legal topics related
to the topic. So I would say that it was really nice to share with my brother all of
these interests and then how this mixed a lot and then ended up being my work now.
So I am really happy. That sounds really nice and it sounds like your
brother is an awesome person as well. Yeah, I cannot deny that. Yeah.
Why did you stack around for Free Software? Do you think it's something very important
for society or this is now a very obvious question that you have to answer it? Yes, I know,
but why do you think it's that case? Yeah, I think that that is the case because basically right now
software is deeply involved in all the aspects of our life. Right now we cannot think about anything
without thinking about devices and then devices also run software and software basically as a
part of our daily life and also it's important that we control the software that it's part of
our daily life and sometimes we're not really used to thinking this way because we think that
software works this way and we just have to accept it while in on the other hand,
we should have the power to control the software that is basically around us our daily life and
until discovering the four freedoms of Free Software, I had no idea that we could and we should
have much more power in controlling the technology that we use every day. So that's why I think that
being able to control the technology is basically a fundamental work and a fundamental right for
everything else that also it's important to control our rights in the sphere of migration,
our rights in the sphere of I don't know, workers rights, anyways, so technology is so involved in
all our aspects of our daily life that it's really believed that it's a fundamental kind of fight
that we have to pursue in order to live in a democratic society and in the end of the day.
I like that. Since you are also using Free Software, do you have a different experience of how
you are able to choose which kind of software you are using or how it looks like in the end?
I can give you an example because in the past year and a half I've also been working a lot on
another file that is called the Digital Markets Act that tries to give back control also to users
in terms of choosing what you can do with your mobile devices and I think that's something that I
think that people should get used to do again. So choosing what you want to use in your daily life
also when it comes to technology and not only think that it's always me like this, that's the only
option I have and that's not true and it's also why I really love Free Software because it really
gives you the power to choose what you can do and what you want to do and what you don't want to
do with your devices and the DMA is a law that basically allows alternative for example
App stores and many people are not used to think that they can choose their own App stores or they
should be able to so that's also why I really believe that point of choice is extremely important
in this regard. I believe that as well. I had just had to smile because you carry them much
about the work that you do that it interests also with your philosophical kind of use and I
really really like that. This is serious. I would love to do a full episode just
the FSFE staff and volunteers for lots of philosophical point of use on Free Software. I think
that would be quite nice. Yeah absolutely. I mean everything is political. Everything can be
philosophical, right? But today, sadly, it's not today that we are doing that. Even so, I really
would like to do that. But today, we will be talking about the Digital Networks Act and short
DNA. It's not the DMA, but it's the DNA. So it's very good that you made the distinction between the
DNA and the DMA because European Union legislation usually loves acronyms but sometimes they can be
a bit tricky. So the DNA, the Digital Networks Act, is a proposal from the European
Commission that has been published more or less at the beginning of January 2026. And basically,
it's a regulation that will overhaul and we will reform our telecom, so telecommunication
and network infrastructure is regulated across the whole European Union. This is something new
because these kind of topics are already regulated, of course, in the European Union, but the
important detail is that the DNA is now proposed as a regulation and not a directive. What it means
that the European Union can produce two different kinds of legislation, regulation, or a directive.
A directive is more of a set of goals and then each member state can decide independently how
these goals will be met while a regulation is a proper set of articles and obligations and
etc. that every member state has to follow in the same way. And this is an important distinction
to make because until now, the topic of router freedom that is included in this proposal was
regulated very differently across the member states because the European Union set the goal of,
yes, users should be able to choose their own terminal equipment, but how this is regulated
depends on the different national regulation authorities. Those are NRAS, national regulatory authorities. So national agency
that work with telecommunication law that will ultimately set the details and the rules of how
this right is implemented in the European Union. But now with the regulation, so this regulation
will apply directly and identically everywhere. So we really believe that now it's the moment to
finally harmonize these rights. Different ideas that are across the member states. Exactly.
This sounds like a lot of work. I'll be as FSFE or basically you as the one working for the
FSFE in this case, aware of all the different regulations because I can imagine it's quite hard
to follow up on all of those or it's just now not necessarily the case anymore because there
will be an harmonization on them. So that will be the perfect end goal. So basically until now,
what's been happening is that we have been following what's happening in terms of router freedom
in all the different member states because as I said before, the different member states
add the power to define what is called the network termination point. And that's a very important
concept because basically the network termination point is a definition of where the end of the
public network is and where the start of the private network is. So basically depending on the
definition of this point, some member states and therefore some users will have access to router
freedom or not. So let's use an example if the public network ends where the socket is,
so basically where you would then connect your router to the cable, then everything that comes
after the socket is basically your property and therefore you have the right to choose your
own router. If the network termination point is defined, let's say for example after the modem
or after the router, you don't have the right to choose your router or your modem because this
is not your property but is still property of the intern service provider in this case.
And I guess just let me quickly ask that question there. I guess that this means that it's
differently defined across member states, right? That's exactly the problem that we're trying
to solve with the DNA because until now there is a general definition that says that
users should be able to choose their own router but the definition of the network termination point
is tasked to the different regulatory authorities of the member states. So basically those
authorities they should follow some kind of guidelines that are defined by another authority
which is the European authority that basically governs the work between all these different
member states. BEREC you mean, right? BEREC exactly. BEREC is the body of European regulators
for electronic communications. So for example is there is the Bundesnetzagentur for Germany
or there is EGICOM for Italy. They are some kind of European Bundesnetzagentur for example.
They produce these guidelines on the definition of the network termination point that the different
national authority should follow when they define this. But of course there are some member states
that they find them. They they they find that the NTP at point A some others at point B some others
they didn't even start the definition. So there is some kind of loophole, there is some kind of grey area
or some other authorities for example, the Italian authorities that basically
at the find the NTP at the point A but then when it came to the find the NTP for fiber networks
it wasn't really clear if the NTP was still at point A. So that's still an open yes because
there's still an open discussion and for example that was also the discussion in Germany. I guess
you also had a podcast recording with some of my colleagues that talked about the latest
news in Germany and that's a similar case in Italy where the NTP is being redefined for fiber
networks. So as you can see there is a lot of fragmentation and European users really cannot rely
on a single regulation defining the NTP at point A. So that's why even if the DNA has a lot of
topics inside it's a huge regulation because it talks about telecommunication, about radio,
about satellite, about many different things. It includes also the article that basically until now
was protecting router freedom so the article three of the open internet regulation and this
article is included in the DNA and we also want to make sure that the DNA already defines the NTP
as a default in the point A so that basically there is a European default for router freedom
and then these national authorities can only be tasked to define exceptions on the definition of
the NTP because there might be exception for countries etc but anyways there is already a
European default that will make sure that the NTP is defined at the point A or anyways as the first
passive physical interface as in localist term we like to say. All right so that's basically the
aim that we want to achieve to protect router freedom and freedom of choice and this we go.
Exactly because sometimes it's important to remember that router freedom sits inside a much bigger
debate or a much bigger idea which is net neutrality. So net neutrality is a very important principle
of the open internet which basically says that your internet service provider so the company that
is providing you with access to the internet should treat the traffic equally so the risk should not
be any discrimination based on the content or the service or the equipment that you use.
So also net neutrality has some freedoms and there are also four freedoms so basically the
right and the freedom to access whatever content you want to access to run whatever applications you
want to run and it's also the right to attach whatever devices you want to your own connection
and also some rights about transparency and clear information about your service plan that you're
using. Anyways but this the right and the freedom to attach whatever devices you want to your
own connection is where the FSFE has been most active on because many digital rights organization
they usually gravitate towards the first two freedoms so the freedom of non-discriminating by
content and also the freedom of treating internet data the same but the FSFE decided to plant
this flag specifically on the device one and since 2013 actually since more than 10 years we have
been at the very one of the very few organizations working specifically on router freedom because it
literally affects everyone with a home internet connection because if you think about it our
modems and our routers are the gateway of everything we do on the internet so having control
on the router and the modems we use every day is this also means having control on for example
how much data is shared with your internet services provider and how to have control with that
or how is your traffic routed between the networks so this is not only a question of choosing
your proper device but having power on how you access the internet and this is this is extremely
important right now why why do you think it's so extreme because at the end of the day is also
where it all comes from why the FSFE exists in the first place so basically oh goodness this is a
I cannot settle for less absolutely fine yeah because absolutely fine at the end of the day free
software is about control so therefore freedoms to use, study, share, and improve the software running
also on the device that we run every day and that freedom becomes meaningless if you don't
control this device your modem your router your modem are devices they are very small sometimes
they are very easy to ignore because they sit there in a corner on an cupboard and we kind
of forget about them because we turn collect a lot of exactly there does take her you know because
we we configure them we install them and then also we never turn them off and they're just there
and we only remember about them when our interconnection doesn't work and we turn around and we say
oh my god what's happening to it exactly or you even forget where you put it the first time but
yeah so if your internet service provided forces you to use the router that they want that's also
a computer in your own running software that you cannot inspect or you cannot audit you cannot
patch yourself if you're able to you know and especially you cannot replace and you're even
though you're banking your private messages your work your backups they all depend on the software
that it's run in the in the routers and in the modems and if you cannot put Free Software
firmware on it or install a Free Software operating system you can also not independently check whether
there is more data collected than it should or if the manufacturer suddenly stops issuing
security updates for your device then your left exposed with not legal rights to fix it yourself
so that's also why we frame router freedom not only as a core piece of net neutrality but also
as a core piece of device neutrality which is also another important aspect of our work at the
FSFE which is basically the broader principle that devices in your life that you buy should be owned
by yourself and should answer to you and not to whoever manufactured or sold the device to you
and this is also include the right to run Free Software on your devices which is not always
the case until now and that's also why we're not only fighting for router freedom but also for
example in the DMA with Apple for example or with Google there are the finance gatekeepers but
that's another that's another podcast yeah and even if most people will never compile their own
kernel in their routers you know they will never do it but almost everyone should have the right
to own the router the seats there in the dusty cupboard you know if they want to so of course
it can be handy to have your internet service provider giving you the routers when you need to
because maybe you don't want to configure it yourself but if you want to you should be able to
have this right also because it's already a right recognize my European law it's implementation
that's that's another question but that's why we're working on the DNA and that's why also my work
sometimes really spans between policy and legal topics you know because you can actively shape
regulation before it's approved you give the interpretation to policy makers you make
them understand why this is important but then once the law is approved there are other stakeholders
involved that might also be interested in shaping the interpretation of of the law that is already
being approved and so we maybe need to go to court to make and make the judges understand why this
is important for technology and for the democratic society or we need to go to regulatory authorities
and not to policy makers anymore that's why also my work really spans between policy and legal
topics but at the end of the day geogep this is the same I like that and I also am very very
grateful for the for the background and the concept of why this actually is an important topic for
us as FSFE as well because I truly believe that this is the case as well so I am very very happy
that we now have this officially on record before we go over to the how can listeners jump in and
what's there to do what I actually be doing you already mentioned that this act that
ditches her networks act is actually quite friendly towards router freedom as far as I understood
so what's then our work is done and we go home and we just lay our feet on the desk or what's
happening there I don't absolutely absolutely not so I wouldn't frame it in a way that the DNA
is friendly to router freedom but at the end of the day it doesn't change the status quo
but until now we are not really satisfied about the status quo so what we want to change
and what we're trying to do and what we will try to do in the next month is to make sure that the
status quo is actually at the standards that we think it should be so basically an harmonization
of the regulation that until now was defining the NTP already written in the low so we would like
to see written in the DNA that the NTP should be defined at the first passive physical
interface which means full router freedom for all European users they will be really nice and we
do believe that this should really be the case and that's why we will be working with policy makers
with other stakeholders in order to make sure that this is what we're aiming for and of course
this involves a lot of traveling to Brussels a lot of talking with different stakeholders but
we are confident how are the talks they're going because I gathered at this is taking up quite a
lot of time for you there and I am really really grateful that you made the time to join me here
today as well because I know how busy you have been over the past two weeks and months so
basically there are three main European institutions the European commission and then the European
parliament and the European council the European commission is the only institution that has
the power to propose a legislation so basically that's what the European commission did with the
DNA in January and then different stakeholders have the possibility to already give feedback on
this proposal in a public consultation and that's what we exactly what we did exactly in February
2026 we produced a response to this public consultation that you can read in our website or in the
show notes of this of this episode for sure and that basically laid down our main ideas regarding
the DNA and our main demands regarding the DNA and then after the European commission publishes the
proposals at the same time the European parliament and the European council discuss independently but
at the same time modifications or amendments to this proposal and to see the light the proposal
must be approved in a equal form both by the European parliament and both by the council so what
happens usually is that these two institutions they will have two different proposals and then they
would meet to then find an agreement to have an identical proposal and then it's it's eventually
going to be approved so right now we're in this phase where these two institutions are discussing
we're so we're working with European parliament and MP's there to make them understand why
rather if it was important and our positions and then actually it's not the whole parliament
discussing the proposal but it's a committee which is the parliament is exactly it's a kind of
working group that works based on different topics and the main committee for the DNA is the
ITRE committee which is the industry research and energy committee of the of the European parliament
so basically we're working with MP's part of this committee and we will continue to do so
after the summer break and then eventually in a some months or a bit less than a year we will
see the proposal being voted by the European parliament and by the European council and then
they will meet in order to find an agreement and then the final identical text will be voted by
both institutions. I have to say that in general we do work a lot with each
or committee but not only also with the imco committee for example the internal market committee
but in general member of the European parliament are eager to listen to stakeholders you know
because of course a member of the parliament cannot be experts on everything and that's also
the beauty of the democracy you know being elected as a person that doesn't know all about everything
but exactly because you are representing someone you also should be very open to listen to everyone
you're representing so that's why usually member of the parliament are of course open to listen to
everyone and then of course there is everything involved in politics so you know yes there is work
to be done that also means we need a lot of support from our listeners because as you know this is
actually quite expensive work to do and we don't have millions to throw around and to invite them
to fancy dinner parties but we are there with the better arguments absolutely absolutely that's
super important as we were saying it's extremely true because already for us traveling to Brussels
is an expense you know and sometimes to meet them or when they invite us to some meetings or
regulatory meetings across Europe we need money to do so it's extremely important that we also when
our listeners see that we got something from or there was a win in the in the European politics
this means a lot of travels to Brussels or a lot of meetings to Brussels and this is this cost
as money you know so we can only keep our good work up for Free Software if we have enough
people who donate to us and as we are charity we really depend on your donation so please think
about making a donation to the FSFE today yes to keep up the good work absolutely back to the good
so you talk a lot with them about how important the definition of the technical point where our
control starts is and how is this perceived do they understand that or yeah is there still a lot
of ongoing discussions our feedback we will link in the show notes so what's happening there next
I personally don't think that's a different concept to understand that's also why I really love
working for the FSFE because sometimes when people are faced with this kind of very technical
arguments they are kind of scared and they kind of back off and say no no no but this is technical it
it doesn't concern me but on the opposite side what I really like doing is try to simplify in the
good way you know what I mean not to simplify in order to make things less valuable or to compromise
but just say look this is extremely important or our internet traffic goes through their
router therefore it's important that we have control on the router but why don't we have control
on the router is because the definition of the public infrastructure ends after the plug or before
the plug or after the router and I don't think that that's extremely difficult to understand of
course there are many technical and many more technical details when when it comes to router
free domain when it comes to network infrastructure that's also why we have some amazing
volunteers that always help us with their super important technical input but I really believe that
the work that the FSFE is doing is also important on the instance so trying to educate
policymakers on the importance of these topics and trying to educate more and more people on
the importance of controlling the technology that we use every day I think that's a really nice
phrase to head over to the question how our listeners can actually support us here as well because
absolutely the network is dearly needed and it's also it's very good if we all talk about it
because I just recently heard this phrase but I believe it's very true that when you are sick
of hearing it it starts to sink in with some people at least and that's the point where you need
to keep talking about it wow that's a very good way to put it yeah thank you yeah I will try to
use it as well that's that's really true and yeah how can our listeners help us of course I was
as we mentioned already course becoming a supporter or the FSFE was extremely important but also if
you want to get your hands a bit dirty and tinker a bit this is I think one of the most practical
topics of the FSFE where you can really tinker so if you want to exercise router freedom we have
our router freedom tech weekend done by our amazing Dutch volunteer that really explains how to
exercise this freedom so there is also a decision tree that basically helps you guide through the
decision of installing your own routers and also gives you a lot of technical details in how to
do so because sometimes another way for an internet service provider to actually not make you exercise
this right is saying yes you can use your own routers but I will not give you any kind of technical
details or now to connect the to my network so that's also way to harm router freedom so that's why
our volunteers put together this this guide to help people that want to start having their own router
and also another way is to check whether your country defined the NTP and if yes where did
they define the NTP if not try to understand why didn't define the NTP which is the organization
that should define the NTP which regulatory authority should define the NTP because we also
maintain a live tracker map of router freedoms country by country so basically listeners can see
whether they already covered or not and if they're not or if the information is missing they can
definitely reach out to us and we're happy to update this this map and another way of is of course
by spreading the word putting router freedom stickers on on free routers postcards or hashtag router
freedom Free Software share this episode if you think you liked it anyways there are many ways
you can help us both if you're technical or not technical person so you have nice skills I would
say I like that and yeah thank you so much Dario for working walking not working but working as
working through all of this and working me through all of this it was really nice to talk with you. thank you
so much for taking the time and yeah thank you so much for being here at the software freedom
podcast thank you Bonnie was really a pleasure I wish you a pleasant day and I hope you have a good
of a lot of success today as well thank you all right this was the software freedom podcast if you
liked this episode please recommend it to your friends and rate it stay tuned for more inspiring
conversations that explore the importance of software freedom and its impact on our digital lives
this podcast is presented to you by the Free Software Foundation Europe as mentioned we are a
charity that works on promoting software freedom if you like our work please consider supporting us
for further information you find more information on the https://fsfe.org/donate Thank you so much bye bye